before we begin i'd like to give a shout
out to the sponsors of this video
with yakuza they create artwork for the
voices of dragon ball z
naruto my hero academia and other major
anime like these amazing 3d lenticular
prints you can even get these printed on
metal or canvas if that's your thing
their artwork is 100
exclusive to their website and they're a
small two-man operation
so make sure you support small
businesses because this is something
unique and trust me this will really
blow you and your friends minds when you
see it for yourselves
the ship fast and worldwide for the most
part so check the link in the
description if you'd like to buy
make sure to use the promo code vinnie
which will give you 20
off your first order
[Music]
as we head towards the end of this
season it seems like a refreshing change
compared to the wasteland that was
spring 2020
rent a girlfriend god of high school
uzaki chan
and other shows have been gaining a lot
of traction and a lot of the sequels are
looking to go towards their home stretch
in
style except maybe for re-zero where the
suffering is just starting
anyway while we're enjoying the current
season with much more positive vibes as
the world at large begins to adjust to a
new lifestyle i don't think that it's
too early to look ahead and see what
next season has for us when you have a
yearly lineup as strong as 2020 has it
only makes sense to become more and more
excited as the year goes on
so what does next season have in store
for us let's find out
we begin this list with the day i became
a god
oh man i remember when the first
promotional picture for this was
released
my social media went wild because after
so many years
we finally see je maida make his return
to the anime scene now if you recall
he's the guy responsible for angel beat
the day i became a god however goes a
tiny bit of
tangent with the afterlife theme of
angel beats and instead revolves around
yuta narukami
your typical boy engaged in preparing
for university entrance exams he runs
into hina
a self-proclaimed god of omniscience
hina has a bold declaration
claiming that the world will end in just
30 days for some reason the girl whose
predictive powers seem more and more
legit decides to stay in utah's home
where they plan to enjoy their last
summer before the end of everything now
i'm pretty sure there's a big twist with
the whole end of the world thing along
the way but i'll let you speculate and
discuss it looking at who's on board
though you better prepare your tissues
whatever the case
at number nine we have haneo no yasha
hime much to the delight of the two
thousands fans
set years after inuyasha's epilogue
yashahime mainly tells the story of dava
and setsuna
seshumaru's twin daughters in a twist
similar to what happened in the original
story dovah and setsuna get separated
and the former finds herself in modern
day japan being taken in by kagome's
brother the two worlds connect
once more a decade later when thor
reunites with her sibling only to find
out that setsuna is now a demon slayer
and has no memories of her whatsoever
joining in the fun is
moro inuyasha and gargome's daughter and
the wheels begin to turn on the latest
chapter of the timeless classic
with bleach and shaman king having been
confirmed to come back in anime form
then why stop here why not have inuyasha
join the party
another of the 2000s most beloved shonen
series is making its return with a
sequel this very next season and it's
been met with much excitement
let's see if it'll stack up with the
rest of the blockbusters we'll be
covering on this list
[Music]
up next is noblies we've seen tower of
god and god of high school
how about the god in oh wait we got
combo breakered anyway what some people
consider the big three in korean
webtoons is going to be completed with
this coming blockbuster series brought
to you by production ig
nominees is finally ready to grace our
screens the intriguing story of a
supernatural noble finding himself in
modern day career has fascinated many
and is now ready to take the anime world
by storm
following his awakening right enrolls as
a student in yiran high school seeking
knowledge of how the world changed since
his 800th year slumber
accompanying him is his devoted servant
frankenstein
who has since become the director of the
high school it's never too late to join
the fandom and watching the anime is the
best way to know what the buzz is all
about
mark your calendars nobody starts this
october
coming up is golden gamoy season three
at number seven
now it's been out for a while but the
historical adventure into the realm of
the inus has been loki one of the
amazing anime series of the past few
years
you might want to head into my previous
video on underrated anime if you want to
know more about the series in its
background after almost a year since the
trailer hit
the third season of golden gamue looks
to continue sugimordo's adventure as
season 2
dropped a bomb of a cliffhanger to us i
find myself unable to see what happens
to our main characters
judging by the trailers that we've seen
it seems that this season will be a lot
more intense and high stakes than
anything that we've seen before from
golden gamuwi how will sugimoto and
aservba reunite in the treacherous
wastelands of japan
tune in to the third season to find out
[Music]
a victim of the numerous delays that
characterized the first half of the year
danamachi is finally ready to roll this
upcoming fourth season season two got a
bit of a lukewarm reception with how the
novel arcs were adapted but with the
delay opening up more chances of jc
staff to up their game and plan things
out
season three looks pretty promising
which is a good thing because if we're
going by where they are right now this
should be around the time dhanmachi
starts becoming more serious
with the coming arc further expounding
on belle's character and motivations
having read some things about the
upcoming arc i'd say that you should
prepare for some dramatic moments that
you've never expected from an otherwise
light-hearted and easy-going fantasy
adventure such as don muchi there's only
a few months left to go before we
reunite with belle and the rest of the
familia
who'd have known that half a decade
after its initial airing that we'd see
godzilla grace our screens again
the old memes say that mad house doesn't
do season twos but
8-bit has since picked up the slack and
not only given us the movie but
this upcoming sequel to the much beloved
power fantasy
season 2 of majorca picks up where the
first one left off
leaving us in a world where magic and
subsequently magicians
have become the core foundation of
international politics
the already touchy sense of bare bones
peace would come to an end when a
mysterious being starts appearing
leaving its victims drained of blood as
tatsuya and the rest of the gang
investigate the vampire incident more
opposition comes their way
as new transfer student angelina kudo
shields seems to have her own agenda in
investigating the phenomenon as a member
of the usna
it's a three-way battle against the
finest of first high
the ace of the american forces and the
vampiric being that's been wreaking
havoc at night
so excited to see godzilla back and
we're not gonna have to wait too long
for it
long time legacy manga aren't the only
relics of the 2000s making their way
back as higurashi is here to represent
the visual novel boom of the period
higurashi in its heyday was one of the
universally praised visual novels
and its anime received the same positive
reception why not run it back and then
sum this 2020 then it's always a nice
feeling to see a longtime friend from
the past
and for those who weren't around in that
time higarashi 2020
is here to terrorize people while
telling them a gripping story once again
for those who weren't able to get a
satisfying fix from the previous anime
then worry no more
signs and rumors point that this 2020
series will be a remastered remake
of one route from the visual novel both
longtime fans and newcomers will have a
blast with this show it seems prepared
to dive back into the world of higarashi
this fall
to your eternity is at number three on
this list from the creator of the
critically acclaimed silent voice comes
this brand new story
about an immortal being that finds
itself on earth without emotions and
identity
it was sent to gain experience and learn
from the world of the living
having the cool ability to shapeshift
taking the form of various things before
eventually gaining
sentiments and meeting a boy in the
tundra finally taking on the form of the
boy who now lies in a critical state
the sentient being now goes on a journey
looking for new experiences that will
teach you more about the world it finds
itself in
now are you familiar with this kind of
plot i sure am but i think that it's not
something that we've seen in anime often
at least in modern day anime i think
that this is going to be one of the more
thought-provoking shows this upcoming
season and wouldn't be surprised to see
this become a sleeper hit or something
like that
jiu jitsu is second on the most awaited
anime list for fall
2020. physically gifted yuji itadori
instead
finds his calling in the about to be
disbanded occult research club his life
takes a sudden
turn when he encounters megumi a
sorcerer on the hunt for artifacts such
as a talisman that the occult club had
unwittingly unleashed yuji soon swallows
the talisman
a finger and becomes the host of a
powerful demon sukuna by all means he
should be exercised but having
maintained control of his body yuji gets
a new mission assigned to him
consume all of sukuna's fingers in order
to kill the demon
once and for all i've always loved these
shonen jump supernatural titles and i
think that jujitsu kaizen has a pretty
unique and interesting setup let's see
how this one turns out will this be a
smash [ __ ] of the season
only time will tell
after what seems to be some uncertainty
it's finally here
it's coming and we'll be getting more
haikyuu this fall fittingly topping the
list of the most anticipated fall
2020 shows the first part of season four
left us
in the midst of the nationals and the
whole world's watching to see how the
next phase of the tournament will unfold
gonosuno's toughest challenge is still
ahead despite the amazing finish in
their previous game which went down to
the wire
what else awaits our plucky hero team
who still have to go through some of the
strongest teams in the road ahead with
everyone's anticipation at an
all-time high there's no doubt that
haiki was the most anticipated title
this coming season
the fervor is there the set is there
let's see if the anime team can finish
with a spike befitting of a victor
and that's it for this list missing
anything i know i know
i think it's best to address the
elephant in the room right now because
as
of the time of writing the final season
of attack on titan hasn't been confirmed
to be airing this fall
its status as of the time of writing
here continues to bounce between
releasing this fall
to being indefinitely delayed there's
been some conflicting reports but with
the state of the world right now i
wouldn't be surprised if the show's
pushed back somewhere down the line
despite that there is a reason for
positivity
as some reports have stated that music
production has more or less finished and
the show probably won't take any longer
than early 2020 to come out besides that
fall
2020 does look really amazing doesn't it
fall will surely steal the show with its
healthy mix of remakes sequels and new
titles
the fun and turn-filled ride of 2020 is
nowhere close to ending
don't forget to like share and subscribe
if you haven't already and hit that
notification bell so you never miss any
uploads
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video with yakuza the link's in
the description i'll see you next time
on vinnie tube
you